[Music]  Megan Kelly's a first week on today  hasn't exactly been a smooth sailing I  read that you said you felt you're not  proud to admit you've had work done yeah  we really want to talk what's been most  fascinating is that it I guess I'm  getting used to that a little bit more  that's a new place for me but her fellow  anchor Savannah Guthrie says give the  girl a break she can do anything  Savannah gave her take on Megan's at  first a week on watch what happens live  with Andy Cohen Thursday I think she's  got you know the eyes of the world upon  her and I think everybody can relate to  you know how nerve-racking that is but  and she's doing a live me she has a lot  of different she can do she's a lot of  range and I think she's awesome